each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
right thank you very much my name is hi
Duke Mashhadi i'm a member of UCLA's
embedded under configurable systems lab
my advice is professor match itself so d
and we are a member of UCLA wireless
health institute in this talk i will go
rightfully over the wireless health
institute us and one what is the mission
of that institution i will present one
of the projects that we are pursuing
equivalent in this institution is
regarding the detecting human imbalance
in real time outside of the laboratory
environment so the whole idea of
wireless health is to leverage the
wireless technology and microprocessor
technology with medical science to
extend the health care outside of the
hospital and clinics so in order to up
by achieving that we can deliver the
personalized health care to each
individual such that the solutions adapt
is adapted to to an individual and that
will make them a capable of being
monitored continuously and globally
outside of the laboratory environment as
languages a connectivity so wireless
health institute at UCLA it's a
campus-wide collaboration and it has
support between industry and community
partners so the whole vision behind
wireless health is that in the future we
have our homes as a pervasive
environment that all systems that
currently we are using will have some
sort of wireless connectivity and we
will have this body and body area
network on the human that somehow they
can talk to those devices around them
and using cellular and wireless network
the collected data will get transformed
to a medical enterprise or a clinic so
there will be designated people who can
monitor patients outside of the hospital
and also there is a chance of emerging
this new model of business which we call
them a call center services so for
example
can register myself to one of those call
center services that they can monitor
some of my world of science or any
health data that I'm interested in or if
they see an irregularity they can notify
the patient or any caregiver so wireless
health institute at UCLA it's a big camp
I mean it it has a collaborator between
different schools schools of medicine
UCLA Medical Center School of
Engineering School of Nursing Public
Health Department under some School of
Management and also collagen bill and
science what the focus on is not just
building a device to address building a
mobile devices to address health care
but it's more like end-to-end solution
that we go we talk with the physicians
in medical community we see what's there
need or they bring us their need and we
try to solve their particular problem
and aggregate that data and make them
accessible for them so and also
developing new tools to analyze that
data and helping them to come up with
better diagnosis and extend the whole
notion of health care after outside of
the hospital so now we'll talk to a
small shoe that we developed and the
main goal is to prevent false why do we
stress on false because as we know
instability is a major cause of mobility
in the elders this is according to
center of Disease Control's so falling
is the second cause of accidental death
in the United States the whole idea is
that according to geriatric experts
there are some precursors to fall that
if at the exact time we can detect them
we can let the caregivers of those
elderly know that some parameter shows
that the patient is has higher risk of
falling so maybe they can then be more
careful about and for example if my
parents one of them then identified with
high risk of falling maybe I won't let
them to go to gross
shop by themself I will be more watchful
so seventy seventy-five percent of all
four victims of fall are elderly people
and usually the falls are responsible
for seventy percent of accidental death
in the person 75 years and older and as
you can see in the graph the the older a
person is the rate of I mean they're the
rate of mortality due to falls is
increasing dramatically also five
percent of all hospitalization in the US
and forty percent of nursing home
admissions nursing home admission rates
are you are related to the people or
patients that have been falling so in
addition to that moral dilemma also
there is highly huge cost associated
with falling so the hospitalization
after fall caused our health care system
25,000 to 75 thousand dollars per case
and the cost of imbalance related fall
in the United States is a has been
estimated to be about 20 billion and by
this is for year two thousand and six
and by 2020 the cost will increase by
approximately thirty two billion dollars
a year which is it I mean a huge amount
of money and also this gap shows that
for people above 65 years I mean older
than 65 years old each fall I mean with
the statistics that they gather from
100,000 people forty to eighty thousand
of those of those facilities value to
fall so this shows that the elderly
people are really susceptible to fall so
how we can basically somehow mitigate
that so we try to bring balance
everywhere is the whole idea of having a
small shoe which has a which has a
sensing and electronic devices in it
plus a software that can extract the
parameters
are important precursor to fall
according to geriatric experts it's a
very it's a portable and affordable
device and also it can be multi-purpose
doctors can use it elderly people can
use it and also it has it can be using
different aspect of our social life like
running doctors can use it to monitor
the patient's data so elderly people can
use it to somehow if they are not
monitored by physicians their caregivers
or they close relatives can lie about
their health condition also we have
tested it with our athletes at UCLA so
runners can use this system to somehow
get the proper regime of running based
on what their trainers are for asking
them to do so with the measuring balance
using variety of techniques the whole
idea is to insight into the users daily
work in Qatar so it's very important to
note that since this is just a regular
shoe I have a pair of it with me right
after the Parker will just pass it
around you guys can see so it's a normal
shoe and there is nothing heavy
associated with it and as long as I have
a cell phone device I can use the issue
and that software can run on the cell
phone and can extract all the data
necessary for me at the end of today and
since its variable and it's not try to a
laboratory environment we can use it
consistently so one of the issues that
we had with the laboratory solutions to
address balances it's very heavily
biased toward the laboratory environment
the fact that the patient can walk
straight in in a room doesn't mean that
he will have the same balance parameters
when they are walking outside in the
street due to do two different physical
and environmental factors so I will hear
explain some of the techniques that
currently is used in by physicians and
geriatric exports to assess human
balance so one of them is gate lab that
usually elderly people are will go there
once in a
and they will work and physicians will
look at how there'll be some of their
gait parameters and based on that they
will come up with either they have a
pool balancer good that we have the
there's motion capture systems that are
that are very expensive cameras that are
again assembled in gate labs that dry
tree expert are using for balance
analysis and there is this system called
pedar which is uninstalled with 100
sensors in it which is costly the cost
of failure is almost twenty-five to
thirty thousand dollars just install and
Bluetooth module even though it's mobile
but it's not affordable for many people
to use it outside of the lab environment
and also there are some cheap methods of
assessing human balance which one of
them is just observational physician are
asking the patience to work up what five
steps turn around walk back and sit down
and they're visually trying to inspect
how the balance is changing so the our
proposed system is trying to take
advantage of different data modeling
techniques to shift the accuracy and and
basically influence the capability of
our mobile platform to detect what this
more expensive system are able to do so
this is the whole architecture you can
see here the first prototype that we
built for our shoe so I have with me the
second one and we are in process of
building the third one so it's just our
show has in the install we have this
pressure sensors its point based
pressure so we perform we make some
study and we find what are the most
effective places that we can place those
sensors and these are adjustable because
the location is very dependent on each
person's walking behavior that means
they should be calibration phase that
they can walk and based on that we can
adjust where the sensor should be placed
so the we have the processing unit which
is a in the first version was a Berkeley
my commode in the second version is a
micro lip it's a new technology built at
ucla's electrical engineering department
we so the microphones they have radio
module we also put a bluetooth
face on top of the value module and we
attach a 383 axis gyro and three axis
accelerometer so we use gyro and
accelerometer for some basically for
detecting some of the gait parameters
that are dealing with the distance so I
also pressure sensor to detect the
hormone II the way people are walking
and you can see that there is this
software that can run in mobile device
and it can be adjusted the sensitivity
of it can be adjusted and there is a
calibration phase that it tries to set
the thresholds and parameters will
repeat for each individual user and it
can after awhile it can report a fall
risk and we have three level of Farley's
the green is normal the orange is
moderate it's not that bad but the rate
is really severe Farley's for risk so
here you can see the monitoring software
of this we just build is for
demonstration purposes but the the
algorithm which is running behind the
scene is the same which is running on
the cell phone device when I demo I will
demonstrate this thing you can see that
when I perform a walk which will have
higher variability of balance parameters
change to the colored of the screen will
change and eventually the system can
notify a caregiver for example the data
that i will that will get transferred to
to a call center they can send the
account set up an SMS or an email
address and immediate message can send
to the caregiver regarding some cases
that system has been detected so here i
will show some of the results that we
got from sure we basically look at two
spatial and temporal parameters of a
human of the gate of the human gait so
and once the look at is the variability
because according to expert what is
important is the variability not the
actual value so if I have a consistent
walk with not so much variation of those
gay parameters that means that as a
person have a normal balance so the
balance is abnormal vendor is very high
variability
so in the yeah this graph shows there
are three types of based on video
experiments and here you can see a three
types of flock the first one is constant
speed walk which is very harmonic clock
the second one is a valuable speed walk
and the third one is inconsistent work
so as you can see the parameters that we
change the variability of the first walk
is almost the first one has less
variability than the second book which
is inconsistent when when we come to a
more inconsistent one we can see the
high variability in the instant I'm Stan
time is one of the gate parameters that
we extract from user there's a portent
thing that we look at it it's the trend
line because the fact that a person can
walk fast and they can gradually slow
down there walk that might show a high
variability in some of their parameters
but when we take out the trend line so
the variability will level up because if
I'm start walking faster and I'm
concerned with the constant speed I
decrease my walk if I take to the
account the trend then the parameters
will show that i have a normal balance
as you can see here for three walks once
we take out the trend you will see that
the inconsistent work would have much
much higher variability that then
consistent book so we also are able to
assess the risk factors so I'm not going
to go to more detail on the algorithmic
side of how we do that I would more than
happy to answer any questions further if
you will have but once a balance what
once there we will have different class
of risks and for each of those class of
risk we will we will we will find the
basically variability range of all of
those spatial and temporal parameters
and based on that we will assign the
risk value and here you can see that for
example in the second graph is that is
the risk distribution that we find in
each of those same type of activities on
human walk and you can see that for
example this blue
one is a constant work while the Green
Line is variable speed walk so we're you
can see that some part of them are some
part of the distribution is overlapping
because in the constant in the variable
speed walk we have a section which was a
constant which was matching with the
constant speed thought but when we go to
much more irregular walk the risk like
the the risk distribution is shifting
more to the right side which which means
that the person would have the higher
risk of all okay so now i would like to
the demo how it works so the idea is
that they will take the shoe outside of
the lab environment and they will walk
the main idea is to collect the data for
longer time for large amount of time a
be day or two days or week i increase
the sensitivity of the system so high so
here i can demonstrate in the short walk
because i cannot work for so long time
that I feel behaving in the real
this is not good
so unfortunately this I know how to fit
this in the screen but now we'll show
part by the time in one time of the
train in right side you will see this is
these are the accelerometer data that we
collect to perform some of our
calculations and you can see in the
middle side you can enter the patient
information and
in the right side there are pressure
associated with eat your food like I'm
in my left folder and my right to use
that to detect harmony so when the
background of the screen is white that
means there is no movement when I start
walking normally it should go to green
and gradually if I start demonstrating
irregular walk it will go to yellow and
eventually red so I'll try to sew all
work so that color change is normal
because I've got some imbalance
naturally that's through to your natural
imbalance so now I will try to
demonstrate limping normal working then
limping which do in order to change the
variability of my work you can see it
goes to read and come back to green and
I will try to show some like when drunk
people they really lose their balance
they go left and right so then you will
be able to see that this is smart enough
to pick it up
alright
that's for my
I'll be happy to answer any questions so
we have staged processing for example
some of the processing is getting down
on the mode like filtering some pretty
minimal yeah some preliminary filtering
then there are some processing which is
happening on the phone so and you can
adjust the vision amount of processing
you want to shift to server or you want
to keep on the phone depending on how
critical the situation of the patient is
yeah actually yeah actually I think your
your phone number was here yeah
honey boo the forest is going back the
patient's my last name yes
the whole
right right
small devices that are unobtrusive
alright
training which could get over some of
the
because you
honey
combination signals
Oh
bro
orphans
ok
sure I as far as your second to your
second comment we are in talk with the
experts outside of the geriatric
department because as I mentioned
recently find that there are other
parameters that might have an effect on
human balance not only the except the
gate parameters so for us we need to
talk to them to get the literature's to
know what's going on we are in process
of that I just find it maybe three days
ago that there is a possibility and they
are definitely ringlets and I wasn't
clear regarding your first question you
want to know have you done any clinical
studies with tissue or I wasn't clear
right
at this moment I don't have answer for
that
and these
very very efficient very not know in an
address book backstage your
this
so very important issue tell her the
Oregon we also became that's different
actually they call us we make them look
like it's different because I kind of
bad is the traditional
they
yes suitable question we've got tougher
better people
not at the beginning so this was
calibrated on my walk but at the
beginning there is a phase that will ask
patient to walk so when they walk there
are some there is a base case because if
a person if there's a person who is
limping regularly detecting leap as a
fall risk might not be accurate so we
will detect all those parameters during
that calibration phase and that will be
the base rule to see because we are
looking at variation variability of the
signal so we had we had four of them and
we gave it to ucla's VA hospital they
did some initial testing but as my
advisor mentioned they have in process
of building 20 25 of them so we can go
for a clinical trial
this is a normal ball this is not and
also can accurately measure contacting
times
compared to those system that i will
show which cost typically
my question related to
ok
so maybe maybe I put a drunk that
obviously the software will be different
when I say it can be used for runners I
mean just the shoe as a hardware
platform so that hardware platform
obviously for the running purpose needs
to have a different software to
interpret data for the way that is
suitable for that particular application
what we had in our mind when you are
designing the issue is having the shoe
to be used not only for balance but it
being as a computational platform that
other people can use for different
purposes yeah well I'm transitioning
doesn't this point
what kind of so the first version was my
tattoo the second version is micro leap